hello and welcome to an early morning
episode
in this one i finally get to prune my
apple trees
so right now we are in about a week and
a couple of days away from
spring which is a little late to be
honest ideally we'll do this in january
or february
but the buds haven't broken yet there's
no green showing
so it's not too late we're still good so
i'm gonna do it now
now these trees are one year old which
means i've had them for one year
um i think when i got them they were
probably about a year old
still for the nursery to grow them
because obviously they have to get them
up to size
so they're about two years old in total
now it is pretty normal for your tree to
be about one or two years old
now as far as pruning goes there's a
couple different choices
most commonly for apples and pears you
would prune them to what's called a
central leader
which is where you have a single trunk
coming up
and then anywhere from three to five
branches coming off horizontally
where all your fruit is going to be on
these branches are ideally spaced out
pretty evenly um it's let's say
two or three inches or about ten
centimeters apart
so they all get their own light and they
all face a different direction so like
north south south east west
you know they all get their own little
space all facing out a different
direction
all around the center of the tree from
the center of the tree
alternatively you could also prune them
and this is most common for stone fruits
in something that's called a vase shape
or
also called an open center this
what you do is you lop off the top of
the tree usually about
30 centimeters about a foot off the
ground so like say
right here maybe a branch left over they
will
all come off down here about three or
four branches
shooting up again spaced out evenly but
they're all coming from the same
the same point that causes problems when
you have
snow or anything like that weighing down
on those branches that's why it's not
ideal
these branches they might snipe off
so what i'm going to be doing is pruning
my apple trees into something that's
called
a modified central leader i got this
idea from steven at home from skill cult
so give credit where credit is due i was
always going to do a central leader
with a modified central leader sounds
even better this is where you're
combining the central leader
and the voice shape combined you have
your branches coming out
evenly along the trunk and they're all
go
growing up to kind of compete with that
central leader
so you don't get that too much of that
apical dominance it's just apples that
parents like to do
so you have about three or four branches
ideally coming out horizontally
growing up all competing then for that
for that main
apical dominance which it helps to keep
your tree small
and i'll explain and document and show
you how i'm going to do this
as we go along so with that said let's
get down to the first tree
which is my calypso so with the
one-year-old apple tree there's really
not a whole lot of pruning that you have
to do
it's more so just guiding it into the
form that you're trying to train your
fruit tree in
and as you do this every year you'll
find that there's just
it's just maintaining the the shape that
you have set up for your tree and it's
becomes very little work really so the
first one
branch it's pretty obvious you can see
it's swooping down
ideally this tree was swooping over a
little bit more
and i had it tied up at the top here to
kind of straighten it out
because it was very it was leaning over
a lot
and that caused this branch which was
horizontal to be very
swooping so i'm going to correct that
first off and how we're going to do that
is by pruning it down to a bud that it
comes out more horizontally
and ideally it's on the top here so
it'll also swoop up a little bit
so this bud right here fits that build
perfectly
so i'm just going to prune it down to
this bud which will take off
all that swooping motion that we've got
going on currently
so here we go we're gonna leave a little
bit of a stub right there
just like that takes off all that
swooping action
that we don't want
there's only one other branch that i
want to prune on this tree and that's at
the top so let me show you that now
so as you can see i still have it tied
up
although i could probably remove that
after this year
as you can also see i've got way more
than the three to five branches that i
was suggesting
i'm not really worried about it i'm
gonna do my own interpretation of it
i feel like as long as it has you know
light then it should be fine
then it will be fine i'm gonna i guess
it's gonna be a little bit of an
experiment but i know it'll be fine
a lot of this is also fruiting wood like
this
back here there's some fruiting wood
i've even got some up here
and down here and obviously don't remove
that down here
i obviously don't want to remove that so
12 branches i'll be leaving
but i'm going to be maintaining it over
the years and i'll be taking you guys
along
now the brands that i was talking about
is that
little fork that you have here and this
is kind of what i'm talking about
with guiding the tree you can see that
i've got two branches coming off of the
same area
which is not ideal it's going to swell
up so you're just going to want to
remove one of them
however if you look a little further you
can see that
this branch is already here
which currently is being shared right
above this one so that's not good these
two are going to compete
for light so ideally what i want to do
is remove this one and then just let
this one
take over because this has more of its
own area
you know this one is a little it's going
on a slightly different
angle than this one down below here
so that's the type of things i would
want you to think about when you're
making these pruning cuts
now i'm going to prune this which might
start sparking
little buds and growth happening at the
cut point here
which you're going to want to take out
when the time comes you could just rub
off the little
little buds there leave a little bit of
a stub
and there we go so there's a little bit
of a stub there
it's a little bit of a stub it's going
to have more branch spark out
and we're going to want to remove those
because we already have a main branch
in this one that's already going to be
the main scaffold so we don't need
that branch any branches beside it
so that's pretty much this tree done
it's it's very minor like i said it's
just small changes that you're making to
the tree
so let's go on to the next one now so
this is my odisso apple
and i'm really glad that i have multiple
trees to prune because it really allows
me to show you some of the different
scenarios that you're going to run into
when you're pruning your trees so with
this one there's really only one branch
that i want to remove
and that's the fact that they
have two central leaders you don't want
that you want just a single central
leader
so that you know you just have one
single trunk coming up where all the
energy can go into
having two is not good it's just gonna
compe they're just gonna compete
together and you just don't want that
ideally you just have one
where all the energy can go into i'm
gonna leave this
branch right here this could be a side
branch
or alternatively really what you could
do is if you didn't
so let's say i didn't want this branch
here what i could do
is prune it off right there
it would then have a new
leader here to take over rather than
this one
but i don't mind this branch being here
so i can just prune this lower one off
and that is what i'm gonna do
so same thing with the other one i'm
gonna leave a little bit of a stub here
and any branches that are gonna come off
of it i might remove
we'll just take it as it happens
it's a bit of a stub
it's kind of hard to do one-handed
but there it goes
and that's really all i want to do to
this tree
one single leader alternatively if i
didn't want it to be this high
i could take down this height down a
little bit this might be too high
ah i don't mind my tree being about
seven or eight foot high
so i'm going to leave it in this case
but you might decide that you want to
reduce the height on this a little bit
in which case she would just take it
down to one of these buds that grows a
favorable direction
so i can take over
you know what actually
[Music]
i might just take it off a little bit
because you're going to get
i'm going to prune this off and i'm
going to have essentially a second
row of scaffolds that are going to be
the canopy of the tree up here
that's part of the modified central
leader
technique there is to have
your scaffolds down low and have your
central leader all the way to tippy top
have a second
um second set of scaffolds that are
gonna keep it small
so i thought i could have to be a little
bit taller but
you're gonna have to take that second
scaffold in the top here you have to
keep that in mind
so i actually will have to prune this
off because if i have a scaffold up top
here
that's going to be way too tall even for
me so i'm going to prune it down a
little bit
and then see where i go so i'm gonna
take
i'm gonna take it down
this is probably about
two meters so about seven foot then you
have to add on another foot
for the second set of scaffolds so
i'm gonna take it down to here a fair
chunk
we'll start with that i could always
adjust later all right
so here we go boom
[Music]
and that's it so yeah so this is gonna
this is gonna subdivide all along here
over the course of uh the growing season
because you know what they do is they
send up a long
straight chute and then they subdivide
later on
so we'll see where the branches come out
and uh next year we'll take the next
step
on to the next tree so the last tree
here
i kind of messed it with this red maple
here but
it's the same thing you can see here
this this main scaffold is coming out
way too vertical okay you can see how
it's not coming out horizontal like at
all like maybe this branch down here is
actually a perfect example
it comes out nice and horizontal this
one
really wants to be the main leader i
don't want it to be the main leader
because i already have a main leader
so this one has to come out that's
what's going to be
the first operation here get in there
burn it off and you can just see
how tall it got
hello kitty yeah so it just got way too
tall
i'm going to be shooting for about seven
foot
as well and then uh extra scaffold
the last top scaffold will be another
foot
so that'll make it eight feet which you
know i'm relatively tall so that should
be comfortable for me
obviously you can adjust this to
whatever is comfortable for you
this is about seven foot a little bit of
a stub here
take all that top growth off
there we go boom
it's done so that's all the pruning i'll
be doing
on my apple trees this year it's not
very much like i said in the first year
i'm not you won't have to do a whole lot
and if you just do it every
year it'll all just become just
maintaining it's very easy
all right guys so that's all the pruning
i'm going to be doing this year
on these apple trees and i really feel
like this modified central leader is
going to be the best way to go about it
for
these apple trees i just think it's
going to be a much more natural looking
tree rather than you know they're pretty
tailored and catered to trees that you
see in a normal orchard i
feel like this is going to look more
natural and i also think it's going to
be more healthy in the long run because
it is
you know there's more more branching and
better branching and all that stuff
going on
and not like the floss shape i just i'm
not a big fan of it even when i do get
stoned for at some point i'll probably
be
pruning them in a similar fashion to be
honest and we'll just kind of see how
that goes
so i appreciate you coming along thank
you for watching
and we'll see you in the next one